mari finalmente si online
mi avevi promesso oppure se sera che fai
aperitivo la città mi cante bicchierino
di vino dai che ci tengo mari rispondi
più facile perplessa mari time a c63
puntini
ma i mari ei ragazzi guardate questo
bellissimo che bello mi ricorda
tantissimo un altro bene state che te lo
mando nov ha detto fini che si fanno
abbastanza silenzioso per una settimana
[Musica]
allora stasera ragazza cenetta e porta
in un posto che conosco faccio beato fra
le donne la bionda e la mora le veline
[Applauso]
no va bene a quanto e sfigato secondo me
ci sta provando di brutto con te ma va
ci sta provando con te ma ti piace a me
per niente a 30 all'ora scala diavolo e
dolci dispiace ma questa sera non
possiamo io ho il compleanno di mio
padre e io di mia sorella
facciamo la prossima volta va bene
faccina col sorriso buona serata manina
che saluta pollice in su pollice in su
pollice in su poi ragazzi venerdì sera
con gli ex compagni di classe
no proprio non ci voglia quegli sfigati
piuttosto nei quattro pochi ma buoni ma
dai ma marino poi non risponderà mai
lurati quando rispondere noi ma perché
lei è impegnata da scorso un nuovo
lavoro secondo me quando mese la mena
silenzioso per un anno tales of the
outer banks 12 13 44 unplugged
tutto ok
la cina è perplessa
meno male che ri stanco lei mi ha dato
la buona notte alle 21 18 sono le 23 34
cosa cavolo ci fai on line se non
riuscivo ad andare a dormire allora
guardava le nostre foto in chat
il fai andare a letto col sorriso
allora va bene niente buona notte a
marina poi fece un bellina con gli
zuccheri nei banchi roma punto
interrogativo scusa
ero in bagno ma allora quella aperitivo
di domani e di cui parlavamo
ma tu non eri fidanzato io ma ci siamo
lasciati almeno due mesi fa e semplici
passi ma stasera io ho casa libera e non
intera fare sono le tra mezz'ora
fuocherello focherello fuocherello
faccina ammiccante ma ma stasera esco
con erika non vengo a cena sto scrivendo
sto scrivendo sto scrivendo
sto scrivendo
ok
7 molto rapida ragazzi e teresa citati
da ieri sera
io sono una donna libero acqua per 3 1
superiore tanto ama la musica che una
cosa gli passa praticamente un video
ieri guarda come la sbronza tiri che
trovi conveniente verde c'è questo fanno
gli amici ma è veramente così misero
cioè moltiplicando umani
no no non l'ha fatta poi è la peggiore
veramente sempre stato un po strada dai
e voi dicevate voi che non ce la vedete
se n'è saputo qualcosa ad essere si è
continuato perché se questo video
arriverà 60.000 like sto scrivendo
gireremo la seconda parte sto scrivendo
se non avete ancora fatto iscrivetevi al
canale sto scrivendo e attivate le
notifiche cliccando sulla campanella che
trovate vicino al tasso d'iscrizione
sto scrivendo e seguitemi su tutti gli
altri social facebook instagram e tic
toc sto scrivendo
[Musica]